translating your family tree into
another language should be simple right
just pick a family member and look up
the kinship term so in Sam hua your
sister is your oh so unless you are her
brother in which case she's your twoth
afina and for the ashanti your parents
nephew is your cousin accept your
father's sister's son who might also get
called father clearly there's not just
one way to talk about family but the
intriguing thing is with thousands of
languages around the world there aren't
thousands of kinship systems in fact
there may only be a handful let's start
with you your generation zero by your
side you have siblings let's give you a
brother and a sister one generation up
we meet your parents mother and father
they have their own siblings your arts
and your uncles upon more and oh look
your grandparents okay back to your
uncle and aunt their children are down
in your generation and they are all
cousins no matter which aunt or uncle on
which side of the family what we just
described is the Inuit kinship system no
not English though we do use this system
see traditionally the world's languages
are grouped into six kinship systems
languages in this inuit system treat
close family differently from family to
the sight of them their collateral kin
now imagine if we dropped this lineal
collateral distinction the terms for
aunt and uncle would become
indistinguishable from the word for
parent and siblings and cousins would
use the same terms for each other which
is exactly what happens in Hawaiian
kinship it cares about something else
too are you a brother or a sister if
you're a sister to your sister or
brother to your brother you use one word
pike wanna but a brother to a sister or
a sister to a brother they have their
own brother or sister words that's still
not enough though you also need to
respect age in Hawaiian there's one
sameness word for an older sibling and
it
different sameness word for a younger
sibling the younger brother of a brother
or a younger sister of a sister are
Coquina who well just like English has
any wit kinship there are other
languages that use the Hawaiian system
to remember the Samoan word ooh so
sometimes shortened to us that's for
sibling sameness too this can get
confusing here let me make you a chart
save it and please review it before you
ever try and translate brother or sister
in a Malaya Polynesian language notice
how these two systems we've been using
lump terms together so many distinct
people under the same word cousin
there's so many different people getting
called auntie and uncle
well what if we broke these apart what
if we gave unique terms to every single
relation from yourself on the tree your
wish comes true in the Sudanese kinship
system if you studied Latin maybe you
tried to map ancient family terms onto
your English ones or Inuit ones in
English that's a strange world but the
old Romans didn't talk about family that
way they had distinct terms for each of
your various aunts and uncles and
cousins your mother's sister is not your
father's sister after all
this isn't just some ancient system
today
Chinese kinship terms are at least as
descriptive as this plus they demand you
pay attention to age
just imagine the piles of basic kinship
terms mandarin has because of this I've
even read that finding the shortest path
between kin members and your family
answering questions like what do you
call your mother's uncle but that gets
tricky enough that you're better off
using computer algorithms to solve it
but hey at the very least everyone is
clearly labeled okay a simpler one start
from our terms
but then switch up how you label your
parents siblings your father's brother
is also called father and your mother's
sister is your mother too it's their
opposite sibling that gets the auntie
uncle status your father's sister is
your aunt and your mother's brother is
your uncle logically the children of
your mother's sister and your father's
brother become your siblings but your
father's sister's children and your
mother's brother's children are your
cousins the result is the Iroquois
system and it draws a very clear line
between parallel cousins and cross
cousins right there in the everyday
vocabulary why would you want a system
like this well you might want it if you
culturally pay attention to cross versus
parallel cousins because you consider
cross cousins and marriage' Baqir
parallel cousins out of it the Ashanti
Kingdom in Ghana have a similar system
but as the British learned through
experience there was a small but
critical difference the Ashanti King
inherits a royal throne called the
golden stool British colonizers were
eager to groom some regal allies so they
sent the king's sons away for a good
English education but they were left
scratching their heads when the golden
stool skipped right past these M princes
see when your father passes away the
next in line to take care of things is
his sister's son that's right on his
death
your cousin becomes your father when
that happens it's a kind of crow kinship
you're still the uncle in your father's
brother and Dion ting your mother's
sister just like an Iroquois but you do
something very interesting on your
father's side your father's sister is
your aunt okay but here's where it gets
strange her daughter is also your aunt
and her son her son is your father it's
rare for terms to cut across generations
like this but in The Crow system aunt
and father do the normal reason given is
that crow kinship pays attention to
maternal lines through the father's
sister if only the British had known you
could do the opposite of this or as a
mirror image start from Iroquois again
but this time used the same term for
your mother's brother and for your
mother's brother's son calling both of
them your uncle and so who ends up being
your uncle's daughter the mother's
brother uncle not the cousin uncle she
is your mother this is called Omaha kin
and if we're gonna blame mom's sister
for crow we'll chalk this one up to
patrilineal societies earlier on I told
you there were traditionally six kinship
systems so then we're done hold on
consider this kin system from South
India it seems like just another
iroquois system parallel cousins are
siblings and cross cousins are cousins
but watch what happens when we zoom out
and take a wider look there's even more
crossness going on
this is Dravidian kinship a system
that's said to prefer cross cousin
marriages
it's complicated if you focus on you but
keep that goal of marrying your cross
cousin in mind and go up a generation
think about the cross cousins your
parents could have ended up marrying
let's circle all the cross cousins who
were their potential spouses for your
mother
and for your father if your parents
married one of them instead their kids
would have been your siblings you can't
marry your siblings so these are your
parallel cousins the ones your parents
couldn't marry would give you cross
cousins and marriage material for you
that is the opposite of what we'd expect
from an Iroquois system fathers male
cousin and mothers female cousin having
kids that are your parallel cousins
while they're opposite cousins have kids
who are cross cousins to you huh well
there you have it our worlds 7 kinship
systems at least that's the traditional
account but before I let you go what
about these questions that kept coming
up as I spent my nights researching
kinship for you what about systems that
are hybrids don't quite fit or are even
seemingly untranslatable also why do
these systems exist where did they come
from
finally I've been using family trees but
what if our assumptions are wrong and
these terms aren't really about
genealogy or ancestry now I don't mean
to sell you a rug just to pull it out
from under you but these questions would
make a great follow up which is
something you can vote for if you are my
patron on patreon you can grab some
unique rewards and stay updated about
native language for you if you're a
patron you should definitely come try it
out thank you to patrons for voting for
this video and to everyone until next
time may you and your family stick
around and subscribe for language
[Music]
you